[Music]
edia will be remembered as a musician
who campaigned to keep the Berber
culture alive his music inspired by the
indigenous North African culture
[Music]
born Hameed chelate in 1949 a tienen a
berber-speaking region in the central
atlas mountains of algeria his musical
prowess began to be recognized by his
colleagues in a gas and oil field where
he worked
[Music]
in 1976 he released avala anova which
soon became a hit worldwide it tells the
story of the daily life and culture of
rural Algeria the lyrics speak of an old
man telling his family stories from
Berber culture the song has since been
translated into various languages
since then idea used the platform of his
rising Fame to campaign for that culture
and identities to be remembered
retail vid mom you his second album was
named just that identities released in
1999
it featured famous musicians from around
the world including Manukau focusing as
Ken Matheson and Donna brass and French
singer Charles Aznavour he's teaching
asthma for his beloved Berber language
when you belong to a minority you start
believing that you're vulnerable that
the powerful can eat you up because even
though your culture exists it doesn't
have the means to develop and survive so
when someone like this offers to work
with you it fuels your will to survive
and even though you're already strong it
makes you stronger
edia went on to write and perform other
albums including Lester sista Lumias
LaFrance dukkha Lewis and the
quintessential idiot
[Music]
he performed them in festivals and
concerts worldwide with his distinctive
voice an acoustic guitar idea has made
the Berber language and culture known
and loved all over the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]